wir haben vier eichen holzbretter man
muss ja echt viel mehr nachdenken
wir brauchen noch mehr holz ich mache
mir daraus erst mal keine werkbank
irgendwann später guck mal humba um
warum baumann
hey ho mycroft freunde willkommen zu
einem weiteren teil von captain mycroft
wir haben es leider im letzten teil
schon angekündigt in der letzten folge
davon dass wir auf jeden fall bockhahn
auf cap des mycroft 2 und wir haben euch
auf twitter gefragt und auch in den
kommentaren ob ihr das denn volt sollen
wird in diesen neuen teil diesem zweiten
teil von captain kreft der viele neue
elemente beinhaltet und ganz ganz coole
sachen hat sollen wir ihn spielen und
ihr habt alle gespielt den und wir
machen das auch heute und ich sag es mit
moin moin kontrovers gesagt wir spielen
der zu zweit und damit einer hat zwar
geschrieben soll eine kleine pause
machen aber dafür haben 99.000 millionen
andere geschrieben wie sonst direkt am
anschluss machen als 200 milliarden
leute was auf der welt haben das
mehrmals unter den twitter post
geschrieben und deswegen am wir uns
gedacht ok kommen es wird nacht aber das
soll es nicht stören weil in diesem
kleinen bereich kolleg ein monster bis
es von deswegen haben uns gedacht wir
spielen direkt auf minecraft 2 es gibt
so viele neue elemente wir haben schon
nachgeguckt jetzt funktioniert nämlich
auch der die sache mit den schienen
funktioniert die sache mit dem skelett
funktioniert das mit dem netz aber noch
ein bisschen warten
und machen wir wieder 100 hans komme ich
mache mich schon innerlich war am ok 321
ok rumba warum warum warum
warum warum warum und jetzt erstmal noch
ganz kurz vorher es gibt richtig viele
neue sachen es gibt hier alles aus lehm
und wir beide lieben leben dass ich
unglaublich cool und witzig sieht so
schön aus aber es ist einfach so
wirklich das ist richtig schön da hinten
kommt zuerst die erste kiste denke ich
jetzt höre ich hab gar keinen baum was
sollte ich denn jetzt machen wir können
man bei den erfolgen gucken die sind
auch eigentlich so gut wie gleich also
mal wieder diese minecraft erfolg aber
wir können uns jetzt hier erstmal nach
unten bauen und da schauen was da uns
erwartet es wird nicht es wird komplett
an masse einen der in den mai kreft
forum wird es so beschrieben
cap des mycroft 1 2 darauf ausgelegt so
vanilla wie möglich zu sein und captain
minecraft 2 ist darauf ausgelegt um so
viele challenges um so viele inhalte
diese sache mit den monumenten dass man
extra bonus bekommt also boni bekommt es
gibt eine viel höhere welt höhe
man kann alles mögliche machen das
klingt doch gut es wurden sogar schon
gameplay tipps gegeben und zwar wenn wir
das mit dem skelett machen wollen was du
die ganze zeit versucht hat ist am
besten wirklich ein skelett nehmen was
außerhalb der boarder steht und alles
mögliche hat er unsere schon
durchgelesen und ich denke das wird
richtig richtig geil und wir bei uns
jetzt erstmal runter holen uns ein paar
items und ich freue mich auf die
nächsten erfolge die wir heute noch in
der folge machen können mal schauen also
wir machen das jetzt mal so k2 kommt bei
mir morgen letztes mal war es ja so dass
part 2 by komme kam jetzt kommt er bei
mir als wechseln uns da quasi ab dann
kommt drei bäume und dann kommt ganz
ungeraden bei kommen die ganzen geraten
bei mir er wolle wirklich schon so weit
runter gehen oder wollen sie erst mal
hoch stecken soll ich mal nach oben
gehen
man kann hier könnte man dir schon
wieder nach unten geht sondern zusammen
nach oben gehen so kacke weil wir müssen
noch einen weg nach oben immer haben wir
können sehr hoch stecken ja aber schnell
von oben sport eng was drauf und fällt
dann runter und stirbt oder mega viel
nachgedacht
ihr könnt ihr nämlich wieder bei der
ersten folge ist und beide sichten
anschauen und danach habt ihr ja immer
noch eine sichtlich behalten hat auch
brauchst ich wollte schauen was da oben
ist da oben ist einfach gar nix oder um
es wirklich gar nichts da stellen wir
müssen auch und heran dann habe ich mich
jetzt mal wieder runter oder ihr sich
darum eine kiste oder bin ich blind
ich hoffe du bist blinde nein ich bin
offiziell offiziell blind bin ich hab
mal um gefunden was darauf warte warte
oder das sieht man am einkommen
in den raum gefunden hat ich hab mich
runter er macht wieder genau mit der
world order wenn man außerhalb ist es
mal rot es ist quasi wie captain
minecraft 1 aber es soll sowas von für
geiler sein und immer ist teil zwei
geiler als teil 1 ist auch im off
monuments genau das kommt nämlich auch
dazu es gibt einen moment der raum
diesem moment ist born immer auf diesen
quatsch block und ja da gibt es ein paar
sachen das werden wir aber alles noch in
der fortdauer dieses projektes
mitbekommen ja was machst du jetzt und
das ist sonst fällt runter oder genau
genau ich hab mich einfach cool hier in
der ecke hier ist ein loch da ganz
einfach unter spring ich hab hier
ich habe eine schaufel ruhm aufbau
siemens alter das wird er sogar so cool
eingeblendet ja das ist echt cool und
auf jeden fall ich habe aus der truhe
gerade bekommen eine schaufel die fast
komplett kaputt ist dann einen stab ein
stück ton 4 goldnuggets eine fast
komplett kaputt spitzhacke aus holz
unten schwert das auch schon halb kaputt
ist okay pass auf jeden fall auf mit dem
ja genau wir müssen richtig fertig damit
umgehen bau erst mal nur so viel wie
unbedingt nötig ist ich mich vielleicht
direkt hier untergraben ich habe angst
dass dann unter lava ist ich würde zwei
kaputt bonn und an dich so gib mir dass
die welt wenn der diamanten sucht profi
war okay auch das eisen aber eisen kann
man ja ich kann mir noch nicht abbauen
und hätte ich kann schon mal ganz dazu
und dann wahrscheinlich wir müssen
müssen weiter und runter weil oben gibt
es nichts okay wir haben auch nur ein
dreier ding ich möchte wenn es eins
größer wird dann ist es ja schon mal
super weil dann haben wir nie mehr diese
blöde world water ihr okay ist das
reisen das müsst ihr erstmal da lassen
wir müssen auf jeden fall diesmal
lediglich ihr vorsichtig wie nur eben
möglich vorgehen kann jetzt noch mal
wieder ein ab genau mache ich hier eine
ecke mal so yeah holz dreimal auf holz
gewinnt dreimal auf holz geklopft wenn
genau um das mal okay 1 vertrag erst mal
abbauen
zack humba humba humba
warum warum warum warum warum ok
komplettem ein bisschen heiser aber
jetzt können wir immer noch nicht
sonderlich mehr machen wir keine
normalen etage runtergehen de mann hat
eine stimme stimmt ich habe ja immer
auch die fast komplett kaputt oder ist
sie kaputt dann alles klar
jetzt ist da ein stein was machen wir
jetzt was hast du denn noch alles da
drin gehabt in der kiste energie ist
nicht alle vier goldnuggets kann ich
hier mal geben schwert hat sich da einen
stock wartet meinen stock ich habe ja
eichenholz und feiern macht den mal aus
dem einmal kurz das eichenholz bitte du
wirst wahrscheinlich jetzt die werkbank
obwohl man muss daraus gemeinde nur eine
werkbank machen
wir haben vier eichen holzbretter man
muss ja echt viel mehr nachdenken
wir haben vier eichen holzbretter daraus
kann man sich nur eine werkbank bauen
wie viel stocker hast du ich habe einen
stock seinen stock was kann man sich mit
einem stock machen ein schwert mehr
nicht wir brauchen noch mehr
wir brauchen noch mehr holz oder sollen
wir einen stein so kaputt schlagen
hier stimmen das geht ja auch aber seine
werkbank brauchen wir ich mache mir
daraus erst mal keine werkbank wir
können erst mal ich weiß nicht oder wie
viele steine hast du dich entscheidest
du hast kein stauwasser traunstein
abgebaut ja ich habe hier einen schönen
gefärbten leben blog da habe ich hier
ich hab halt da mal keine steindl
ansicht ich habe mit mir weiter
verlangsamt haben die spitzhacke oder
hast du die wie oft hast die spitzhacke
verwendet nicht oft also okay gut du
warst du eigentlich dabei immer dass das
wieder von unseren anderen blog jetzt
leitet dass das schon so ein bisschen so
wie etappen weiter
kommt aber was ich weiß nicht
guck mal ja warum warum warum man war ja
sein echter niemand mehr holz ort
berichten
vorsichtig sind wir haben viel gedacht
diesmal wo man nachweise von anfang an
das unterste truhe weil wir beide das
ganze ding aufs sofa anfang an
angegangen sind oder die karte ist
bestimmt viel schwieriger als nahrung
äpfel wasserflaschen ich habe mal zwei
fans schon mal hier mitgenommen
einreichte wenn wir hier eine stehen
weil du bist gerade wer roboter billig
weil er auch ein roboter nähe du gehst
bei mir bei mir ist doch wird das
verkehr
ich nehme die kiste auch mal mit also
wollen wirklich vorsichtig genug
vorgehen damit uns sowas nicht passiert
beim letzten mal blabla so ein paar
sachen genaue schlimmer weil die
werkbank hier auf jeden fall auf dem
smart eine uns im alltag und wollen wir
uns mal hier die beste machen ich finde
das ist ganz schön mit dem ton und alles
und da oben ist ja gerade alles nur
voller humba humba humba humba
also falls ich ein paar leute ist gerade
denken kochen machen denn die beiden
sparten da das wie gesagt hans ausgibt
auf minecraft 1 und was ich jetzt kann
auch schon seht ihr denkt zwar nur
bonner hat sich bisher diese das ja
alles gemacht das wird mit mir
synchronisiert ich habe jetzt auch den
erfolg mit der spitzhacke zwar geschafft
in meinem erfolge screen allerdings bei
den erfolgen bei tab hat nur gott den
geschafft das ist richtig gut weil das
wird jetzt quasi getrennt und kommen
liegt zwar vorne jetzt mit den erfolgen
aber in stand trotzdem jetzt die erfolge
weiter fortsetzen weil sonst musste ich
dir dann immer nachholen dann hat das
mit den erfolgen ist gar nichts gebracht
und jetzt ist das wirklich so ein
kleiner wettkampf aber war das ganz
natürlich jetzt nicht überstürzen ich
bei uns erst mal die besser sieht man
hier die kiste hin und die spitzhacke
stelle ich auch mal schon mal die ersten
steine ab damit wir gleich schon mal
bessere ausrüstung genau auf jeden fall
ein schwert ist erst mal wichtig weil
wenn wir sterben und sachen verlieren
durch den krieg oder so dass wir heute
das wäre echt blöd ich lege jetzt mal
ein paar sachen daran zweifelt keiner
nicht mit den ton also dieser leben in
der ecke koma wollen wir den abbau
wollen wir denn da stehen lassen ich
weiß nicht ich habe ein stück ton im
inventar war ja weil sie den hier ja was
ist das jetzt das sogar tun kannst mir
erstmal spitzhacken machen oder kannst
mir die sachen geben nachricht gleich
mache ich sofort warte mal ich brauche
noch ein paar steine ab und dann haue
ich direkt ein paar schöne hacken
irgendwie passt mit kubala jetzt kommt
nicht mehr hoch egal weil ja du hast er
genau buch so ok achtung ich glaube
gleich kommen wir da humba humba tanz
ehrlich bin ich ganz sicher wenn das
aber noch wasser flach humba humba humba
humba humba humba humba
beim umbau so krass da ist wieder sonne
sonne möchtegern potato dir es sich
diesmal nicht
die wird nur umbenannt orville apetito
aber das ist eine giftige das habe ich
gelernt minister leiter ich habe mit
spitzhacke ist das nicht wunderbar oder
steine super und zack ich habe schon mal
ein schwert das heißt wenn du älter du
wirst ja nur was von egal wie viel zu
schnell was ich will jetzt noch schnell
wie nur ganz normale sachen sind stein
schwert und so ich nehme diesen leben
halt einfach mit ich habe ihn jetzt mal
mitgenommen abgebauten mit 16 leben
wahrscheinlich kann man sich daraus
später briggs machen und ausblicks keine
ahnung hast müssen wir mal schauen ich
muss die ganzen erfolge auch noch
nachholen hier auf jeden fall packen was
man gerade mal nicht braucht es ist
wichtig weil wenn ich jetzt sterben
sagte wenn du mal überlegt diese ganzen
einfachen erst folgt jetzt alter diese
ganzen einfachen erfolge jetzt am anfang
hast du ja alle geschafft und ich habe
mir gedacht ich kann ja eh noch alle
nachholen um den score aufholen kann ich
ja nicht ich hab dir auch automatisch
geschafft ja eben 30
das ist voll doof dass du die alle
vorher gemacht hat macht aber keinen
unterschied
oder eher doch jetzt hast du die ganzen
erfolge punkte bekommen und ich gar
keinen aber ich habe sie immer noch als
reine ja klar aber das ist so geil sagt
christin höhle kolja kannst du mal einen
blick reinwerfen was brauche ich ja
eigentlich war das ganze wieder ab jedes
mal auf unseren base werden hier schon
mal schauen wir schon mal hier fühle ich
komm nicht aufkommen konnten star war
also in der relativ klein und
unübersichtliche also ich ja ich weiß
nicht die hülle gefällt mir nicht
wirklich gut aber wer direkt wieder
alles schön machen ich blöd man kann man
ja später immer noch würde ich mal
meinen verstand denn genau ich brauche
mal für dich auch ein stein schwer okay
obwohl warte mal ich hab noch vier
holzbretter so ich mir damit wirklich
jetzt noch nie bei mir ein holzschwert
haben reicht das erst mal ich habe herrn
stein schwert
das kann nämlich hatten stand wird
direkt packt die steine die das holz
besser da rein wir müssen vorsichtig
sein weil wir bisher noch keine
setzlinge haben eben richtig stimmt sind
die ich da oben lesen die nicht so
leicht ist oben bei dem monument was
gespannt auf dem monument blog das kann
ich mal eben auch gerne erklären wir
beide können noch mal hoch ich gehe
lieber noch mal ganz kurz hoch nicht
etwas für sich genommen jedoch nicht ich
nehme auch die kiste mit die hier stand
das team schnell wir können auch das
eisen abbauen kann wer mehr eisen jetzt
fraglich ob überhaupt immer das eisen
mit habe ich ein gesammelt ich hoffe mal
robbie ist ein held auch da habe ich es
ok ok ist ja klar dass man mit dem
moment ruhe sofort wird hier verschüttet
ich bin sofort da kommt das ganz oben
hier sieht es auch schon deutlich
schöner aus oder wir machen uns doch
hier hin mit dem mond im methoden ja das
ist natürlich auch er das ist tageslicht
halten als in die kanalisation immer die
sachen von unten mit wir müssen uns eine
coole treppe noch und haben gesagt wir
sonst von annika einstellen ob nicht
gerade bin
du bist aber am völlig falschen ort ich
weiß gar nicht wo du hin möglichst die
bands bon punkt also wir sind hier in
diesem raum angelangt und haben ja hier
dieses jahr starten sind dass sich aber
diese blöcke die übereinander gestapelt
sind
wenn man hier angeht steht hier red
steyn play also roter clay muss darauf
rein theoretisch denn das ist ein raum
die kriegt man bonus sachen von der
karte sinne das ist so ein challenge
raum
das heißt hier steht okay man muss diese
glasglocke gegen roten leben ersetzen
dann erhält man irgendetwas das weiß ich
nicht weiß keiner was an da erhält das
sehen wir nämlich in der nächsten folge
weil das war schon wieder mit partner 1
wir haben schon muss man's oben auf dem
weißen blogger auf diesem claim blöcke
oben verordnen die gleich wenn diese
sachen dann irgendwie gleich freigesetzt
werden bei dem nächsten erfolg den dem
in der nächsten folge die kommt dann auf
meinem kanal die übernächste comcom und
dann werden wir dieses ganze projekt
wieder richtig leben weil wir es lieben
und wenn es euch gefallen hat dann zeigt
uns mit einer bewertung und dann sehen
wir uns in der nächsten folge wieder
also heute rein mit